we have new be good to yourself teas in
summertime colorways like banana salmon
and more check them out at
theovonstore.com baby get that hitter
today's guest um is a he is an
endangered species of a man
you know he's really um he's something
you don't see much he's hard to catch
many shadows
ah
he's a real disco ball of a human he's a
cadbury egg in a in a world of jelly
beans um
he's
the most requested guest that we've had
and uh i'm grateful that he's back
uh catching up with him here at the
hollywood casino in florida
it's dale d'antoni
jody high roller mr riff raff
for me to set up
[Music]
that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
oh
it's always tough
you got it it's like being at a rope
swing you got to wait for somebody to
kind of try it first you know mm-hmm
especially when it's silence out there
and then and everybody's watching yeah
when everybody's watching now you're
thinking from the outside point of view
yeah and you're looking at yourself
and you're thinking too much and
sometimes
you know
study long
study wrong oh really yeah study long
study wrong sometimes overthink it oh
man well i yeah and i've been doing some
wrong
i've done some wrong there yeah so
sometimes cuz because the first time if
i'm hearing a song of mine or something
and like i sometimes don't even listen
to the beats unt i don't like if i hear
a snippet or something i'm like oh i
like that then i'm gonna go i'm gonna
hit pause and just leave it because i
don't want to hear it too many times
because i'm gonna forget
the energy that i had so you know what
makes you keep keep listening
hold on let me just get that because it
once it becomes work yeah
you lose interest yeah wow
so why is that i wonder you know why
i get i guess a lot if so a lot's riding
on something but if a lot ain't riding
on it you know i mean i guess if it's
like you're trying to time a
a jump or something
and there's trains passing by oh yeah
and you're trying to time it right where
it's like okay that's you've got you
need to study for that because if you
[ __ ] up yeah you might not make it but i
think if it's like
a tire swing
it depends if you how much you like your
ankles yeah frank you know
it could be dangerous out there
i'll tell you this baby you're back man
i'm back it's been a while three it's
been three years damn since i
brought you mangoes yeah big mangoes oh
they were good too good mangoes yeah
they felt good man
you know anna nicole smith died here
in this hotel yeah
from what
they said
drugs i thought it was from being thick
okay
maybe she mixed too many
it's always somebody mixes uh oh upper
with a downer yeah or a downer that's me
with
alcohol
and they fall asleep don't wake up
or somebody put something else
in the
upper yeah made them go down mmm
that's just got to be a dark surprise
yeah i don't like that kind of stuff man
a lot of stuff out there and now they
got i mean everything has something in
it you can't get that real clean uh
drugs like you used to
and i can't you i i don't use them
anymore because that's one of the
reasons yeah they quit making good stuff
yeah they put fentanyl in everything
it's but i mean you don't know what's in
it just cause white powder might be
sheetrock yeah and fentanyl people like
people don't have any
oh yeah like it used to be
i mean the way i see it in the 80s when
it was
cocaine blowing up from blowing in i
mean a strong wind yeah just
dust your stepmother over that [ __ ] was
good from colombia or wherever and it's
and it's and it was and it was good and
that and now there's and you want and
you would have repeat customers yeah
because it's the best the cream of the
crop
but although when somebody say cocaine
then it's all there was was cocaine
there was no fake of that because it
this is what it is yeah
you know so then as time passes then and
everybody gets spread out the population
growing then you have people selling a
fake version of it because they're just
in and out of town they're just trying
to make their little money they don't
care if they kill somebody or not
because it doesn't they don't know
anybody there they don't they don't care
they don't have to take pride in their
work right that's a shame man i remember
people used to take pride in the work i
feel like
no matter what it was
yeah man i don't know what killed anna
nicole i think he had drugs
and uh
i don't know
you believe in ghosts yeah definitely oh
damn but it makes me sad to think that
ghosts would still be on earth because
if you
are here and you don't go on to
somewhere better and you're trapped here
how long
can you and if other ghosts are there
and you hear about people being like a
ghost in the house or haunted house and
if they're trapped in that house loud
ghosts
yeah or they buy them are they is it a
is it only bad spirits and then they're
if there's good ones are they is there
something in the in the middle or are
you trapped here and it's bad and you're
just like trapped here and then it makes
you think it makes me think this then
if ghosts are trapped here and that's a
punishment obviously because you don't
go somewhere good then then what are we
here
if it's bad for them after
right is that for us what does that mean
yeah maybe we're ghosts maybe we're like
ghosts that people could see real well
like because with blood in them
or something you know i'm saying like
because yeah if you go
i guess if you
if you die right
and you suddenly you think cause you
probably all at that point if you read
prepared to die
you know
then you're like all right you got your
fingers crossed you know
that's that roshambo with the lord you
about to see what the deal is
and then you just suddenly just a damn
ghost now you're invisible but still
hanging around in the same neighborhood
you gotta i guess how at that point then
what do you do
that's where it gets scary because if
then because if there's ghosts and then
it's like like i was saying like how
long are you there right by yourself and
if can you see other ghosts
they got it you have to be able to see
other ghosts i can't imagine you just
sitting around as being a ghost
and you can't even
talk to the other ghosts yeah
come on man don't be like that bro don't
make a world where if people did they
get nobody else to talk to unless that's
their punishment or is it or or is it a
choice and they choose not to go
on because they they they're
unfinished business i'm gonna stay in my
house
it's my house hoa [ __ ]
i paid the hoa fees for this for that
baby yeah
yeah i'm staying here boy
i just paid up yeah what if you pay six
months rent in advance run your diet in
the first month in a flood or something
i got a solid five months left [ __ ] i'm
here
so
yeah what do you think happens ref you
go
god get you know you get hit by the
lord's lightning bro something happens
to you you get licked or something right
off the earth
where what happens to you i like i like
to think and be honest bro okay
so i like to think that
you know how like steve jobs made an
iphone
right yeah
in that iphone there's not anything
that's in that iphone
that he doesn't know it exists he put
that camera there
he put the when you hit one it goes to
one it's a touch screen it's this that
like every aspect of that so as a you if
you're
you are using that phone or if you're
the phone those things were instilled in
you
by the steve jobs right so if i look at
or bodies like iphone
if you're feeling sad you're feeling
things you can't explain you're feeling
like you love someone you're feeling
like whatever you're feeling or your
thoughts or something happens
or you're whatever it is
that was instilling you that chip was
put in you
so for that for to feel sad or
compassionate you see a puppy and you're
like i wanna hold it i wanna
you know loving someone doing something
that you know there's no cameras on
you're doing something good yeah and
you're doing all these things i think
those are instilled in us
you know when that like uh
like whistling
doing something joyful you mean yeah
just happiness joy when babies are born
they are born
mean they're born into you know they're
innocent and most kids are are more
compassionate than adults because they
haven't been through all the other
offices emotions that they they feel
so i think that
all those things that are instilled in
us
that
it didn't come from us
right somebody had to install that in us
so
you got to go somewhere good there got
to be something better yeah than what
we're dealing with here
that's and sometimes that's all i got to
keep going hey man
i feel that man
yeah sometimes i'm like yeah
then
that hope that excitement
that there's something better going on
if i keep that in my head and in my
heart then that even helps me behave
better towards people too yeah you know
because that's my tough thing sometimes
that is good man i get i get a lot of
hidden anger comes out of me you know
damn like i got a damn [ __ ] raspberry
gremlin living inside of me bro [ __ ]
looking for licorice dog that thing is
[ __ ] damn eating eggs in my ass bruh
and not washing the silverware dogs
something inside of me that just like
wants to get out you know anxiety anger
frustration sometimes of
doing i'm doing this this this this all
these things and
you know and then sometimes people
smoke a little weed or something that
takes the edge off and they and then as
you get older you realize okay maybe
that you know maybe that's my mike tyson
smoke so much it keeps him cool and that
works for him you know some people
they take the take the edge off and some
people have a couple of drinks and then
some people
if they're already an angry person then
when they drink then that side of them
comes out and that's when it's you know
dangerous or the end people end up in
jail domestic whatever the case is but
it's like
i think
like trying to like noticing
i'm getting angry and then also like how
we're talking about a little earlier
where it's like looking at yourself from
the outside like
being able to stop and be like let me
look at this from the outside
am i
am i being like out on a movie and then
there's the angry dad that's like
yelling at the kids and beating the kids
yeah that's not the cool guy in the
movie right so stopping what you're
doing and trying to take a step back how
do i be the cool guy in the movie
i don't want to be the angry
the angry dude who's yeah who's who's
not who's [ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah
fighting his wife [ __ ] punching
somebody punching tiffany punching
[ __ ]
don you know or ricky or somebody yeah
yeah i feel you trying to take it it's
hard to have that peace man noticing to
like you know i mean noticing that when
it's about something's about to happen
it's bag and then also taking a note and
then eliminating that from
what what what was the what are the
pieces that made you be mad if you if if
throwing the lawn and doing laundry and
you're throwing the laundry and it's and
your hand is hitting the the thing and
your back is hurting and you're getting
mad and throwing some [ __ ] and breaking
something throwing the radio and that
breaks a thousand dollars
what's cheaper
hiring a maid to do the laundry yeah so
you don't get mad and so your laundry
ends up in a nice pile so you can go do
some other [ __ ] and and
and and you get still got a radio or
you know so you start to understand why
like people are walking around you see a
rich guy in a suit yeah walking around
with a girl looks like um
off of scooby doo jinkies what's her
name oh
ashley marie no ashley lynn olson
what are you talking about no like uh
velma yeah and with the glasses on with
the note velma was fine huh
she was lit she lost something other
i know that's about right
come on boy you know take it to now some
sometimes you need a like somebody who i
mean once you get to a certain point if
you're
mom's even like that you need an assist
like moms need a you could a mom can't
take care of three kids that's why one
kid grows up enough then that kid can
help the mom or he's sneaking out
going over uh stealing sunflower seeds
oh yeah from the squirrel uh bin yeah we
used to do that
tree and then he's stealing some of our
seeds don't don't do that yeah we had a
dude like that brothers one kid in our
neighborhood this dude named daniel bro
he would get up and he'd be eating right
out that bird feeder bro something was
wrong with him he like he thought he was
a bird
something he sip off that [ __ ] bird
bath too brother he just wanted that
dude
right he wanted to he wanted to just you
know have an egg come out of his ass bro
something he just loved that bird life
yeah though out of all the animals
of all of them all right there's only
one species that when it's out in the
wild and it's doing its thing that
somebody's like oh [ __ ] i got to go call
the uh child protective pet services
mm-hmm
if a bear's running around wild they
call it if a dog is running across the
road
sometimes they call it yeah it depends
if
you know
it's puppy's going in the back seat yeah
he's taking it huh yeah yeah and then
but like uh but birds yeah if you see a
bird you can't do nothing about it
that's true
they're wild
hawks eagles even the most vicious ones
bro we should start calling cps on birds
bro by the time they get there they're
in south florida
connecticut but for the but that's the
thing they got to start tracking these
animals bro because they know where they
go yeah a lot of them have flight
patterns they're with a couple of their
buddies you'd think that they would be
able to figure some of that out because
they got to start tracking these dogs
man
i would want to be uh birds what what
what would you what animal would you
want to be
well now that you say yeah birds are the
real one that can get out of uh you
don't have to have any real battle
there's no
issues with the society
you don't run in any court date nobody
yeah you gotta do jury duty mm-hmm
one time i came outside and um
way out in the country and and um these
vultures oh like the size of that that
right like that right there i don't sit
on track all of that beer tap no this
this just just this oh this thing this
piece of about the size of that chair
right there oh yeah and they're in
they're in the tree and and when one
bird was on a huge limp like it's a big
pine tree them and it it leaned down a
little bit i was like okay these are
like 50 pounds plus
big birds and they're looking down and i
was like what are they looking at i'm
looking out the window i go outside yeah
and my little frosty is laying down
sideways so these vultures were just
looking at her they were they're as big
as her
they're thinking about dinner huh
thinking about going down there and
scooping some ice cream up getting a
couple fries and a frosty yeah damn
thinking about that they looking at you
like damn you work at a damn wendy's
brother they think they're about to go
down there and get served that'd be
crazy and there's nothing you could do
because birds cheating go right back
into the air they're gonna swoop and
swoop with the claws
tell me this man i've been thinking
about this how do you die bro when it is
man how do you go out
if you if you get your way
and be so
did i ever show you the what the hell
i think i talked about last time right
what the hell what the health the
the documentary
i don't know if you did or not
you might have you have a greater memory
than me okay so so
like i i want to be as
healthy as possible and eliminate as
much health problems as possible
you know and and try to be a hundred
i think is a good a good solid age man
if you can make it to a hundred because
i see people at uh at the gym this one
dude drinks he's like he's like 74. and
he's in there every time we get in the
gym
every time we go to the gym he's already
in there working out eight nine in the
morning and he's he's he's in there
until after i leave but he's he only
goes in the mornings he and i was we
were talking to him in the last tall or
short he's about a little about my
height okay wow
and he's 74
in shape and uh and he
he said uh
he drinks one cup one cup of breast milk
every day no
he said he has 20 he has 20 something
kids
and his kids
have
kids
and then
the mothers or even the daughters or his
daughters
i think he had the kids just to continue
that break keep getting a couple so he
never runs out of breast milk he said
one cup it was somebody somebody's
having a baby and somebody get a cup wow
do it
i wonder does it have to be drank out of
like uh
does it come from his own family then
i'm guessing he'll do that i'd ask him
that he said yeah
one cup i wonder if i could handle it i
wonder if it would i don't know how he'd
if i'd have a reflect you know i mean i
think you just got to do it like
just i mean you know you're you know
like ever
mix it with some uh ginger ale
set it up
set it out in the sun for about two days
right yeah maybe dog i don't know if i
could ever have any breast milk man you
know actually i knew a girl uh
this girl tommy larry she has a friend
who has breasts who will
does breast milk out of her breasts at
parties and [ __ ] oh no but i don't i
don't like all of that bro i think
breast milk is
if i you know i wouldn't drink it out of
season what's the season for it i don't
know what what i don't even know if i
could do it like that
is it like a you know like they have
that thing at starbucks that comes out
what is it the
like the uh the pumpkin spice yeah
calzone yeah like maybe in the winter
time i could do it you know smell
calzone do a [ __ ] lime kiwi [ __ ]
licorice
croissant
right they put such just a shot
just a little yeah you'd have to have it
with something i'm saying if i think if
you uh something's wrong with you
yeah or have something before it i don't
think you go and just have breast milk i
don't know i don't think i would maybe
like melt some like vanilla bean
bluebell ice cream and you got a shot of
that boom take that back then you go
breast milk and then you go melted uh
vanilla bean uh bluebell again
you know i think it would overlap it
yeah i think yeah you'd have to manage
it well because i don't know if you
could tell your neighbors and [ __ ] about
it i just i don't want to be doing i
don't like to do things in secret
that's what hurts me i think
yeah yeah i'm trying to i try not to
ever lie because man
eventually you just like
it'll become a problem for you anybody
lie to somebody i can remember that i
lied if you have a lot of somebody
that you you're around all the time
or you want to be around mm-hmm
then
it's just all it's going to do is just
go now you're going to have a
relationship with that lie
right then you're living right next to
your lives
you don't want to have that so you want
to just be honest and then if you got to
lie to somebody
maybe you just ca just keep them out of
your life so you ain't gonna lie no more
yeah tell two or three lies to them and
tell them to [ __ ] hit the road does
anybody ever recognize you and then you
you tell them they say hey are you
theovan and you're like nah man
yes sometimes man the other day i was at
the airport and i wasn't doing that good
they'd shut down all the food places you
know so i was trying to [ __ ] make
something out of just a couple items at
the little quick stop yeah and they
don't have a lot of good items you know
they i
commandeered a couple lunchables out of
there and so at least i had a couple you
know some protein options that was the
closest thing to a
uh
you know a real entree in the whole
joint so i had me two lunchables and i'm
kind of putting something together i was
trying to do it in secrecy i got to like
a gate that didn't have anybody added
so i'm over there got me a little plate
bro things already been delayed three or
four hours i'm sitting over there
stacking my stuff up
um got an extra thing of string cheese
and i broke that down
you know uh into you know
you know uh similar looking pieces and i
kind of put myself a whole together a
little bitty sandwich okay and this dude
came up bro and man i just i think i
felt ashamed of myself for being you
know sitting on the air
florida airport i mean you're just
trying to chill
yeah i know there's something about a
man like an adult [ __ ] with two
lunchables open no children around just
[ __ ] you know it looked i think from far
away it looked kind of sad
and then he said are you theovan and i
said not today i'm not um
yeah and then what'd he say he said no
worries man i understand bro oh okay and
that [ __ ] just felt [ __ ]
i felt like i just didn't even take care
of my kids
sometimes i mean sometimes people come
up to me they're like are you theovon
and i'm like nah not today
not having a dude oh bro i will tell you
this dude i went to the sherwin
williamsburg okay and they love you up
in there though yeah oh dog they love
you
paints oh dude if you had oh and crayola
crayons but sure wins if i could i could
name some paints if you had a riffraff
lime bruh
caramel back hair bro that'd be my
[ __ ] i paint my whole house
thunderstorm gray
oh what about this
[ __ ]
mauve
i would say or if it was like a mob i
love some mild tones i would never have
like marvelous
[Music]
what about this bro
uh
what about
diabetes
that color
the color bruh i think i would be proud
on the up and up of the positive things
or what about this okay what else
cured diabetes
orange
that's nice it's a nice
nice uh
melted uh
yeah like a melted flintstones
uh
push-up pop type deal it's a nice orange
yeah
yeah i think i would love it if you did
sherwin's but i went into sharon
williams bro and the dude goes man you
know who you look like dude bruh
and this he was like that dude that says
dude bro you know he's like you know you
look like dude
and
and i thought he was gonna say me i
thought he was joking with me
and he go you look like [ __ ]
riffraff dude then he goes i love that
and he said the n-word a white dude
they know me
they know me yeah that's it i was like
damn that's cool as hell bro if a white
person calls you the n-word and you're a
white person bro
that's like as good as you can do i [ __ ]
with you yeah they [ __ ] with you hard
man i feel like black people would let
you say the n-word man they don't i feel
like
do whatever i want
because i i select who i'm around or not
yeah
you know
you gotta you you you don't have to
watch your mouth watch your tone around
your your friends you know i mean yeah
to a certain level where it's like
i don't gotta answer to nobody
and i can choose who i even want to be
in my world
and when i i learned at a young age i'm
better at yelling than explaining when i
start stuttering it's because i'm trying
to say some [ __ ] that i feel
like what the [ __ ] am i even explaining
for but
then if i care about somebody i'll try
to explain something and i feel like
damn i feel like i'm explaining to
grandma why i've got a face full of jam
30 minutes for dinner
go clean off your damn britches
rubbing that damn strawberry raspberry
medallions all over you
all of your superman briefs
and now a word from our sponsor
how we care for our minds and our brains
affects how we experience life
if you're seeing the world one way
it may be because your brain
isn't
comfortable
so it's important to invest time and
care into keeping your brain healthy
that's what better help does
better help online therapy
i've used it i've been on there
you get face to face on your computer or
phone with a therapist
and you start to get well you're not
alone better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
only therapy sessions
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to that's also
an option it's more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours
tpw listeners get 10 off their first
month at
betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o
that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash theo do you know why
free trials renew without your consent
are you are you do you know why
why free trial you suddenly you look on
your bill and you got trials for this
bubble gum
uh monthly
and you over there getting um
uh boomerang weekly and somebody mailing
you a boomerang every week
and you're getting billed by dang
netflix or um
you know uh harper's bazaar or something
well true bill
can help
truebill is the new app that helps you
identify and stop paying for
subscriptions that you don't need want
or simply forgot about
on average people save up to 720 a year
with true bill that's a lot of money
you can get an old car for that much
money
companies make subscriptions hard to
cancel they trick you true bill makes it
incredibly simple
your true bill concierge is there when
you need them to cancel unwanted
subscriptions so you don't have to if
you're afraid to make the call or can't
do it yourself don't fall for
subscription scams start canceling today
at truebill.com
t-h-e-o
go right now
truebill.com theo it could save you
thousands a year
bro my grandmother bro
she hated me bro but she you know spent
time around me so you know she liked to
have me around i think so so i would
know that she hated me okay
but
anytime i would go in the bathroom
brother wash my hands urinate whatever
she would bang on the door bruh and ask
me if i was doing a bowel movement in
there
every time bro
it just
she didn't want you to
she don't give a lot of context with it
she was just like are you doing a bm and
she would oh she would write it down on
a little thing when we did it oh wow
trying to monitor your like what time to
eat or what time maybe something like
that you know maybe she didn't want us
like you know messing up that porcelain
probably yeah yeah tinkering up that
porcelain
don't be
don't be putting those stains on my new
pores yeah you bootying up that pink
porcelain now i think she wanted to know
when we was she was that kind of lady
she wanted to know when you was going to
really [ __ ]
that's a certain type oh bruh she was
hardcore bro she was like a real uh
you know military colin powell or
whatever real militant minded oh
she was sergeant
sergeant streaks yeah she really was man
real sergeant streaks dude i'm grateful
to have you here man i wanted to ask you
too bro i was thinking about um
you know
a lot of rumors bro there's a lot of
rumors out there in the world always
and you believe in rumors it it depends
who who the source is honestly where
where it's coming from but you never
know who heard it prior to i mean it's
it's
it's a 50 50 thing and then it's just
like you know if we were sitting in a
circle and somebody say something it
really it really it depends which person
is telling the information oh yeah and
how f how
[ __ ] up they are
are they drunk telling the story that
they aren't supposed to be telling and
they have half the information and
saying it wrong oh yeah did they hear it
the other way and then how are they
going to translate it so it's usually
usually sometimes it's just because if
it's a if it's a good if it's a ba if
it's something bad if it's a bad story
if it's a ba if it's something that's
negative about somebody
something it could it could be a just
complete lie that somebody made up
that's very specific and they're trying
to [ __ ] this person up and then there's
no way out of it you already got [ __ ]
scenes
on it you know what i mean grandma's
blood on that door but if it's good yeah
then it's a 50 50.
if it's bad it's it's 10
that's how i see it right right the
rumor that's bad is probably 10
chance less credibility yeah on the bad
ones right that's uh that's what i've
learned that's fair man especially if it
has something to do
with a wealthy
male oh yeah if it's a wealthy male and
it's something bad it's probably 10
yeah it's probably been a lot of it
could be calculated there it's very
calculated everything's a smear campaign
when it's something bad that's if it's
someone but if somebody's saying
something bad
about somebody who who's successful have
has money
chances are it's a smear campaign yeah
yeah it happens a lot man dude i
remember we would play that game
telephone remember where people always
say that thing in a circle somebody say
something you say it's somebody else and
i grew up in you know in louisiana and
half the time we'd come around and be
like they would be at the end of the
line you know
and we had this one kid bro the same kid
i was telling you about earlier brothers
kid daniel he would always
uh we'd play it at school with the
teacher right yeah so we would come all
the way around and she's like all right
dan you'll say what you heard and he
would yell the n-word bro
out of nowhere
and it was his plan the whole time bro
he was just waiting it would be like you
know uh mom likes shortbread and it
would go on you know somebody got a
short horse and then it's like deandra
you know ride a short bus and it would
keep moving around and then he would
yell out
just yell out the n-word you're like
damn classic daniel and they kept from
there the same every time they kept
really like they kept yeah
the teacher had no plans bro but so i'm
what i'm trying to really i guess ask
you is a lot of rumors out there about
you you've had a lot of stuff in your
life about music
art
and i'm hearing that you might have a
thing where you want to get into
politics and stuff like that
are you serious yeah i'm serious man i
mean
no
but if i mean how much does it how much
is the how much they pay you to be the
president only thing only way i do with
politics is if you know how people can
go viral or song can just magically go
viral from 10 years ago 20 years ago if
somebody did a dale dan tony for
president campaign and that [ __ ]
actually went they're like well he's
over 35. well he's born in america well
you know what we gave [ __ ] uh [ __ ]
weekend to bernie's guy
we gave him we gave [ __ ] you know
what i mean we gave carl from home depot
the [ __ ] president was like just to
get the other guy out like [ __ ]
[ __ ] it
let's go the rock rocks like no i got
movies to shoot [ __ ] you go dan tony and
everybody's like you know what like
let's just get a [ __ ] american
[ __ ] real actual man in there to
[ __ ] run the show and and and listen
to the people and do all this [ __ ] i do
it
but it's not it's not like that but is
it something so you would do it if it
came to you if it came knocking on your
door you would do it put it like this
it's like everybody asked me dude like
oh you should have podcast you should do
all these you know have a pocket
i i don't feel like i i could set that
up and organize that the only way i i
would do that
is if like you were like oh you know
what i'm gonna
fully set up this riffraff podcast and
then show me the division
for coming from
someone who's who's already massively
successful in it so it would have to be
something from
the world and they want it
they want it and they put it together
and [ __ ] it i'll be i'll be president
and uh now i'll actually try
but me doing the whole campaign and
actually trying to be president or
trying to be i'm gonna be the [ __ ] a
mayor he could start with a mayor city
council with city council sounds like a
lot of work a lot of suits a lot of dry
cleaners
[Music]
a lot of lunch and can i bring my dogs i
think these are questions that i'm like
i gotta even ask the hoa what's some of
the rules you do right when you get in
there they put you in there man
are we talking mayor or talking
president
um
i would say senate or lieutenant or like
governor lieutenant first of all i'm
like all right where y'all got me
staying at
is it a guard gated
senate penthouse
so you want that upstairs spot i need
them off states yeah
we're going to like what what are the
per what are you what like i need to
know where i'm at where i could set up
is there a homeowner's association in my
home
are y'all giving me a house or just
giving me a whole bunch of [ __ ] to do in
a pile of papers and be like oh you got
to find your own trailer so you want
housing
not just housing
my bad
big
a
just give me an
arena okay
all right all right
corrugated and what you're going to do
though
it goes around the entire thing and one
drawbridge goes down
that's what we're doing first we'll
build a moat all right
10 feet because nobody's 10 feet tall
alligators
and then what piranhas
oh damn
do alligators and piranhas even get
along we don't know
so imagine if you fell in that you got
i'm not doing that they're already been
practicing oh i ain't being in that room
no so when they have to try to get me
out after them four years or i don't
know what is it two and a half months if
your senate
i don't know what it is they just shot
that one guy see
like
fame isn't even
state said oh you you want that smoke
baby you put my grandma in the prison
in 86. yeah i'm like i just started
being sent it you didn't get my grandma
your
your
your great-grandfather put my
grandfather in a headlock
yeah you know
now i'm dealing with the previous
prior terms of agreement you're dealing
with old [ __ ] you used to steal steal
cinnamon your grand grandfather stole
cinnamon from somebody i knew
you stole the you stole cinnamon toast
crunch idea your uncle rodney yeah
he had had his fist so far up my ass
he took my ideas
he took my identity yeah i'm having an
identity crisis yeah yeah and it's
really just a gallbladder issue it's
somebody who just got who
they're it's a four-year-old
they're leaving comments
and now you have to deal with that now
you're losing sponsors because somebody
made five
fake ig pages
saying they don't want you to be
senators they're kicking you out for
toddlers yeah
damn
yeah you're right man it's a lot
politics i feel like it would give me
more anxiety
minority
do you have a good bit of anxiety you
think every day really
people wouldn't believe it
and what do you take for do you take a
special juice or something what are you
doing right now before you do massages
do you go to any type of like uh
you know i do therapy twice a week i do
mention meeting yeah more talking only
time i talk is
with you
or maybe my pups
my pups are my therapy oh they are
that's your therapist huh dang well they
say they have equestrian therapy people
talk to um horses
i don't know if it's horses or not but
it's a they talk to
they talk to different animals
yeah i guess it is horses equestrian
yeah that's a question damn bro that's
brave as [ __ ] dude the first dude who
ever did it must have been high on drugs
bro
roll up to a horse and start telling him
what was going on
i mean if you set your phone down and
set everything to the side
and you sit there like in the in the
midst of like
a horse or your dog that you raised or
whatever like yeah
and just and and you're talking
regardless if at the energy energy is
israel
you know and the vibe is real and they
say horses calm people down and that's
and that's true
i i feel like that
you know um
so i think when you're talking to your
if you were you raised my puppies right
my friends i'm raising them and
everything and they they know
they know my energy okay they know my
whatever if i'm throwing [ __ ] around or
if i'm mad or i'm throwing something or
slam the door
they might get scared at first but they
don't run away from me they know that
something's wrong and sometimes like if
i'm just if i do something
and then like well
i mean i just think about jody just now
but like
i
they they they understand and they come
near me so they're almost more
supportive like they know hey what's
going on you know i i i believe that you
know i i don't think even like we get to
go back to the caveman times everybody
there wasn't any language now there's 50
different languages or something like
when you talk like you you're not in
your stomach and you're like exerting
this energy i think some things
like communicating
doesn't have to be words like sometimes
you you know if you have your
loved one near and like
you know sometimes just holding a hand
or hugging or something like that not
just a random person but maybe but maybe
you know what i mean i think sometimes
best communication isn't even
words
so therapy could be
yeah that's a good point man they could
even have therapy where you just go and
hug somebody or hold somebody
petting horses brushing a horse could i
feel like that would be a lot more
stress-relieving than
kickboxing talking to somebody and and
then paying them 300 bucks to
tell you what
your problems are that maybe they got
the same problem or they got other
problems that they got to go to somebody
else talk about maybe it's good though
maybe therapy is is good i haven't done
it you should try you never tried it no
really
man you got a guy i guess but then also
sometimes i think you should be able to
pay the therapist based on how it went
if you're good you get 60 if it went all
right you get 45. you know you know you
need a little cup of coupon or something
yeah i'll be like i'm gonna get you next
time yeah yeah i'm gonna get you we're
gonna see what you got next time
therapist person yeah we'll see how it
goes man this couch is this couch is
itchy is it no i'm saying you're laying
down on the therapist couch oh yeah
there's a wool i'm not laying on this
damn thing not this one this is good
this is a nice quality belt
nice quality velvet
but uh i just is it like a spa type
setting in there or is it bright lights
beaming in you know i think some of the
times i go in there it's kind of
chilling dark books behind you okay they
talk about getting better they got a
picture of a guy on there getting you
know in it he's like
some guy's crying by his bed or
something with his penis out okay
and then a couple books have pictures of
like a brain on them which book you pull
and then the bookcase twists around and
then you're like oh i don't give a [ __ ]
about anxiety there's a mix
adventure and a treasure back here
all of a sudden you're wiping your tears
on your gucci sweater and [ __ ]
running back there like damn forty five
dollars an hour
damn baby this isn't [ __ ] you know
escape room yeah i think i think i think
people if we
if everybody lived the life like it's a
movie i think people wouldn't be crying
as much
you like did you ever see the goonies
yeah i liked the goonies man my cousin
knew a guy who uh
worked
with a guy who used to who you who was
who worked on goonies
okay
he knew he did what did he say about it
and he went forward just that was that
he was just bragging
like yeah my my brother did the makeup
he did the makeup for that yeah remember
when uh and it's like just tell us your
brother's game bro yeah
don't tell us all of this crazy [ __ ]
yeah my brother did the makeup for uh
bad boys four or something you know okay
or christmas with the cranks
yeah my cousin got beat got beat up on
set of christmas with the cranks at
night when the set was closed down damn
what about this though man
you've had a lot of interesting things
in your life music
art
michael jordan reenactments
that's true what about that family bro
you going to get a family or what's up
soon one day really i think in the next
i want my huskies to
play with my child
you know honorary i want to have my
huskies play with see my kid you know
and
i think that would that'll bring more
bring life
you know it's like i've had i've gotten
puppies for the big one you know and
then you get another puppy and then you
know what i mean yeah i think i think
that they need to they need to see a
baby
yeah roller needs a low roller baby you
know a little baby riff or a
little
you know ain't no telling do you think
about it sometimes i think about it it's
always been kind of spooky to me yeah
yeah it's definitely like something that
you it would be life-changing but
i think it comes time just like in it
like if you have it in your mind when
you're a kid like eventually you know
then you're gonna get to time like all
right well it's about time you know
it's like i think like i think every man
should event like i believe with my
homies before we lived in crazy houses
in l.a or wherever and you you know it's
a fun time oh yeah i remember last time
you told us about living with simon when
y'all first when you first moved out
there with him yeah but i think of
eventually you get to a point where
you're like
well
i i've lived with my friends before like
you know i think when you're about like
30
it's time to be like oh when i go home
or i got my
woman at home you know
because i think just eventually you even
if you got your friends and y'all go do
whatever like eventually you're gonna
get tired of
doing everything yourself you know i
mean
yeah it gets lonesome
boring lonesome you start thinking too
much being less productive
you know yeah i even got me one of them
dang body pillows one time bro a full
bot it's like a supposed to be like not
a woman but
they say you could put perfume or
whatever on it yeah
pretty much but but it can't just be
anybody no because because that that you
know goes back to the energy thing like
if you aren't
yeah you got to be something you know i
mean and then that's where
it's like
all right like this is something that
i'm gonna have to
you know
organize not what's the word
like that it's it that the thought of
like having a child in your mind
it's getting close to that time you know
i mean or if you're getting out of shape
it's like i'm gonna have to hit the gym
pretty soon
you know what i mean right it's a little
bit of that same thing almost like
there's something inside of you that
says man something
yeah like i come home and i have a
sandwich or i make me a taco yeah i make
tacos probably five nights a week okay
i'll make tacos too i'll make some mean
uh dale dan tony uh tacos yeah i gotta
make you some yeah i would have
something about out on the ponderosa
baby get out there and fill my damn
holes with them but i'll say this man um
fill my holes with them oh bro
if i dude i [ __ ] love tacos so much
bro if i could bro if i had taste buds
in my colon i'd put one in my okay well
you know it's one way to do it and then
there's other ways there's one of them
i'm just saying bruh yeah i want that
you know i want to see what that yeah
now don't super size it though
that's what's wrong with that regular
size yeah with that baby talk
um
but yeah man i think about that because
that's always been spooky to me bro is
trying to thinking about having a kid
just a [ __ ] always scared me getting
married yeah you ever been married never
damn bro
and me neither brother yeah no i think
simon either there's
a few like mutual acquaintances as
friends that
they
and he's he's just now he's having like
he's not in his prime yet i don't think
he's you know he keeps remaking his face
every time when i talk to him i'm like
you know like naked gunn 33 and a third
and yeah like i could see him being that
and then finally blowing up steve martin
like you all you remember him he had
i remember only time i saw steve martin
when he had white hair yeah so when he
was in uh three amigos and hot or in
high school anything what was the one
where he was the one where it's like he
was the dad oh uh oh i know you're
talking about uh father of the bride it
was it was meet the parents before meet
the parents uh oh my girl
both of those those
he was great bro yeah he's he's doing
this in my favorite movie
above the rim
no oh that's your favorite bro we know
that probably he was in uh clash of the
titans no the one where he's the uh the
preacher the traveling preacher do you
ever see that i watch it god bro what's
it called it's called uh
[Music]
i think snake something snake something
let me think damn bruh
well we'll look that up it had like a
picture of him on the front of the thing
yeah when i we with with with kids that
that gives me anxiety because i know how
like
cautious and like how much i
care and just about my pups
so like with the with the kid i know i
know
and i the more i like hear about like
people having kids and
that are like they keep they homeschool
them and stuff because they don't want
them going out into what's in the world
right now like
you know that's
like it's just out of control
i mean and again there could be a
million schools and then one bad thing
happens that's gonna be all over the
news that's right i understand that the
new percentage is low but i don't even
want that percentage and i think in the
first 10 years of a child's life
it's almost like a uh
hard drive or a
sim card a sim card you know it gets
full
right like a sim card that you're taking
pictures so you're downloading your or
an ipod you're downloading all this
information for the first 10 years and
then after 10 years unplug it and now
you're using that information you're
playing the songs
and it's updating your apps and you're
but you're you're uploading all you're
getting those
those initial things that are like the
basis of your entire life i remember
[ __ ] from when i was between one and ten
more than i remember [ __ ] from
when i was 20 30. yeah you know what i'm
saying and we we still probably live off
of those things i live off those old
operating systems you know what i mean
you know so so
i would want my kid i would want to be
right there definitely for the first 10
years make sure they're protected you
know put tennis balls on the edges of
all corners and yeah so nobody's busting
their face open and you got to be there
because
that's when the kids are going to
remember
either
my dad loves me and my parents love me
and it's not even going to it's gonna be
subliminally already instilled in them
they're gonna have so much confidence
that
my parents got my back my dad always got
my background let's go play this let's
go do this like i can call my dad then
they get into that pattern of doing that
where if you weren't there then that in
first 10 years if you weren't there
every day it doesn't matter if you owe
they aren't going to understand like oh
well he was working he was the one
paying for this if you aren't there that
day all you remember is that they didn't
have a close relationship with you and
it's not going to get closer
so i think that first 10 years you got
to be right there like i see how like
cal dj khaled loves his kids i can't see
them going to no public school do you
have if you want to eat teach them
something they come they come together
they probably have a tutor or something
to build a little school in his house or
they learn maybe learning a different
language maybe learning math maybe
learning whatever but i think being
around a kid being around their parents
is important
and then they they learn how you act
they learn how you do things they learn
how to
now it's time to like okay let me not
smoke around a kid let me not drink let
me not you gotta be on your you know you
wanna be yelling around and all that
[ __ ] dude so do you with that did you
feel like your environment was like that
growing up or you would give your kids a
different environment
i would i'll give them a way different
environment but i also love both my
parents and they were doing like they
were doing the best that they could yeah
they were doing the best they could like
i don't look back at them like oh i hate
my dad right
you know i hate my mom or something you
know because it was different
too yeah and ultimately they
whoever your parents were even if you
don't like them
i can't speak for everybody but it's
like you're here the combination of
those two
made you be here and if it was
somebody else was it wasn't your if he
wasn't you wouldn't even be here right
so just remember that before this is
yeah that's how you got here so when
it's like you see like
stories of like
like
kids like
oh uh um some kid in high school
couldn't damien do this and then yeah so
yeah good point yeah damian he killed
his parents because they wouldn't give
him they wouldn't let him watch cartoons
yeah at nine uh you see that sometime
dang yeah they had one kid his parents
wouldn't let him go to the dance and he
killed his whole family
and it's like
and he couldn't even dance that good
they had a video of him dancing
he wanted to learn how to dance
i mean it just what what i mean like i
guess i guess i remember going to the
dance as a kid or not
uh i re i would go to the skating rink
oh yeah you would
see that
like a damn endangered species
and i'll skate a little bit but i'd
mostly play arcade games but just the
vibe
of and it was like a black light in
there and they had a little dj dude
they had a dj up in that little dj pot
and you just come in there and as soon
as you open that door it's a cold wind
and it's chilly in there and you just
clean
you got in there huh man then you you
see the little stars on the floor
circling around
it was a it was a vibe and people were
out there now did all the skating did
they have the lights out on the whole
time or every now and then they put the
lights out and let people skate like the
night like they had that like the you
know the little spotlight thing or the
stars and stuff yeah i think they maybe
cut it on cut the all the lights on i
guess at the very end to be like it was
basically a club for kids you know but
but it would be an uh
pretty pretty dark on the not too dark
but
you know what i mean yeah like yeah you
get out there and you you gotta wait and
just like double dutch and get in there
and just start coasting then you go out
there and bust your ass a few times and
then yeah you know if somebody sees you
and then george michael they would play
george michael sometimes too a lot of
george michael billy idol gay dude what
kind of sneak out billy joel you'd see
like kids you didn't know was gay or
their brothers was coming out you were
like damn this seemed like a
different energy out here a couple new
guys out here yeah some grown-ups out
here what are they doing yeah yeah like
they aren't all the way growing up like
why's petey's step dad out here suddenly
bro you got his shirt off dawg yeah it's
a 23 year old he has like
a home tattoo yeah
he has like uh we had a girl one time i
saw a girl had that [ __ ] smoke tattooed
on her oh what
that change that that really made me
think about everything right
what was she what was what were they
doing what was she on i don't know she
worked at a slotsky's over there
the sandwiches yeah i used to i used to
get the everything uh bagel and then i'd
get like everything in it i'd get some
corned beef hash oaf roast beef ham
turkey yeah bro the lettuce i'd even i
don't even normally get much but i get
regular mustard in there
spice it up god
yeah dude i think i just realized if if
a bunch of people beat the [ __ ] out of
me if they said some of my favorite
foods while they were punching me i
don't think i would mind it that much
you know if they were like creme brulee
[ __ ]
i'll be like oh [ __ ] but yes i like it
okay you know
yeah i'm just trying to think about that
man
um
has a girl ever punched you
oh i'll tell you this dude
so i was in love i don't know if i was
in love with this girl but we were you
know
we were kids and we were [ __ ] okay
you know
and uh
and she found out i met i fell in love
with another girl
and she found out about it and she came
up and ran up to me one time when i was
with the other girl and she hit me
and i didn't know what to do bro so i
[ __ ] fell down okay it was kind of
like delayed though like she hit me and
then i kind of was like oh [ __ ] because
i was like if i stay up i got to deal
with her and her standing right here
arguing
the best thing i can do right now is
kind of fall down because then at least
it's like hey i'm taking a i'm out of
here yeah you know
i fell down and i answered any questions
oh bro i was horrible i pretended like i
was unconscious that was the craziest
part
it's a good way to do it i guess it
could have been it could be hard you
could have yeah
it would have been crazy though
ah [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] up call me
which one of us just run
no nothing else
yeah man that was the girl i know i lost
my virginity to that girl bro behind a
bowling alley over there the first one
yeah
the punch the punchy you had a fighter
she must like you did she ever talk to
her did you talk to her after that ever
yeah he's got a text from him the other
day man really yeah we had some issues
later on and oh we ended up splitting up
a couple times putting air in each
other's shampoos and [ __ ] we was oh
that's a different we was looking for
interact we were looking for a court
date you know
but yeah i lost my virginity over there
behind a bowling alley over there
tiffany lane's over there and some kids
was throwing rocks at us bro oh [ __ ]
pretty cool
that's on rocks yeah they didn't like it
i think they were christians or what are
just jealous one of the other okay but
it's hard to stay hard when you people
throwing rocks at you
yeah especially when that's a good
metaphor for
for life yeah
it's hard to stay hard
people throwing rocks at you yeah thanks
man
does coffee sometimes make you feel a
little too activated
sometimes i notice that about coffee i
have it and i'm like i don't this isn't
it's got me feeling more anxious than it
does
uh
just alert
well mud water is different it's a
coffee alternative
and it's
it's it's providing me with a it's hard
to even explain it's providing me with
just
more feeling more of a comfortable
activation
it has four adaptogenic mushrooms mud
water does
it has ayurvedic herbs it has
one-seventh of caffeine as a cup of
coffee
so you get the energy but without the
anxiety jitters or the crash of coffee
yeah you just don't that's what it is
you don't have that edge off that come
down
you don't have that like grit in your
you know it's just not too much it feels
more manageable each ingredient in mud
water was added for a purpose
cacao and chai for mood
lion's mane for alertness
cordiceps to help support physical
performance and it has shaga and rishi
to support your immune system
mud water tastes great
um
it's whole 30 approved
it has cinnamon in it i like that it's
got that little hint of
it's 100 usda organic non-gmo
gluten-free vegan and kosher
mudwater allows you to build a morning
ritual that promotes sustained energy
without the crash that's it again it
feels more manageable go to mud water
mud wtr.com
theo
to support the show
and try something new
use code theo for 15 off that's
mudwtr.com
to support the show and use code theo
for 15 off
what about you bro when you first get in
the sexual world brother you have first
have a real
interest in it
man i was so much into basketball
but you had to stop and get into sex if
even for a half time or something
it was it was like after
i was done playing basketball
i was like uh
how was i
20.
damn did you break your heart
no
you broke her heart
no oh damn
y'all just sit in it it just i know what
you didn't
nope wow
y'all just met somewhere that it was
like a a
dark area
like that i think
i think um
it was like the
it was like the first
first time i got drunk i think
i didn't get drunk or smoke weed oh
really or have sex till i was 20. wow
was you real um
yeah i was man i thought i was
if my friends would be in the car
smoking weed
i'll put the window down
i was i was about a basketball i wanted
to be in oh wow yeah i want to see how
far i go and i think uh
when i stopped playing basketball or i
started i stopped being
because i was playing for
a college
and then it's always been if the coach
loves me
i'm
and i'm getting playing time and like
it's it but it then i'm great if
if somehow
[Music]
the coach don't like me and i'm on the
bench i'm gone um because i can already
see it and this coach
it was game uh we had we had just had
we were but it was the we had been
practicing you know you practice
practice practice practice early morning
practice they have two a days get up at
six a.m and then you have four o'clock
whatever it is and we're doing all these
practices and then the day before our
first game
he brings everybody to the gym
and we're sitting down
and he's like now y'all can't be it's
like 6 a.m y'all can't be telling uh
uh other people and people around campus
that you uh got a scholarship here or
that
you you're
you're here on a full ride or that
you're doing this and bragging about
this and you're uh and drinking and
partying and expect to be playing
i'm just like i'm sitting there the
whole time
remind you i haven't drank i haven't
done that
and it's like oh simcoe
they've been telling me that a few of
our uh players would tell me that you
that you you're going around telling
people you got a full-ride scholarship
and you're going to be starting and that
you've been
he's from minnesota i don't know why he
has a texas accent but he's also yeah
but who knows maybe he traveled
yeah and then he's like you and and
telling people you have a scholarship
and you're gonna be starting if it
you know if i hear any more of that
you're gonna be on the you're gonna be
on the bench for the whole year
to me and i'm looking around i'm like
which one of you and i was about to be
starting oh and then so when i heard
that i was like
this is this is this isn't good damn
yeah and so you left it no so then right
after that we had a game that night and
he didn't start me but i had been
starting the whole time in practice
so then
go the game
and i had and he put me in like in the
second half and i think i had like 15
points
all in the second half he didn't even
play first out but let me start the
second half so i was like okay this is
where i just proved right that i could
do this because if we have another game
we have like a tournament next day
because it's early in the season so i
had like 15 points on the second half
like so i'm like okay well he obviously
sees if i played the whole game i
would've had 30 points right
15 points
next day we go to michigan and we had a
tournament
bench whole time puts me in the last
three seconds it's freezing cold we
drove on the bus from minnesota to
michigan it's eight hours
drive or something
and we're all the way over there it's
freezing it's icy roads i played like
three the last three seconds of the
first game but then we had another game
that night
didn't play me the entire game i was
like as soon as i get back i'm done man
and that was it because i did everything
i could right
and it wasn't good enough for well you
know i mean i can't deal with the
i can't deal with it with with someone
controlling right my outcome
later that night then i got drunk
damn
bro that's funny bro yeah i don't like
having someone having control over my
outcome man
i'd like to be the one that has
determines what happens to me
i think that's why a lot of people end
up like
leaving a job that was paying a lot of
money but they had somebody telling them
what to do 24 7
or
having too much power over them and
they're under their thumb
and they're
dictating their life
that's not good for anybody
you
if you could go back would you do it any
different because sometimes i think that
i i i i end up damaging myself by being
that way a little you know it helps me
and it hurts me kind of the only the
main thing if i did
i think i'm right where i'm supposed to
be now yeah you know what i mean
i wouldn't rather be nowhere else
but one thing that the one the one thing
i do different in the past is
i was on diplo's label
and i wanted to be more free
i wanted to do whatever i want drop
whatever i want now looking back after
neon icon i should have
stayed focused and been like all right
we got to do another project that tops
neon icon and i can't drop another
project
until we top what we just did right
and what ended up happening is like i
just
kept doing what i do dropping videos
songs do whatever i want whenever i want
right and and sometimes and and and
if i go back i'll be i would go stick
with the script that they that he had
we're still friends with still you know
my brother works out yeah you know they
do but that that that one
thing and and spend more time with jody
husky and and taking more places yeah
probably those two things stick out to
me most that that probably come across
my mind
you know of things you might try
different might try something different
yeah just pop up in my brain just
periodically throughout the week didn't
have popped up in my brain for the last
years you know like oh dude yeah
i got [ __ ] like that yeah i got some
little skeletons that come by what what
do you have anything that you would you
would change in here yeah i think um
i would probably let i would trust other
people more
i would trust like uh
you know i never wanted to have a
manager or anything like that you know i
never really worked worked well with it
so i think there's times when i probably
could do a little better if i trust
other people and just believe hey maybe
these people
do have some of my best interests at
heart they're not just trying to get
money or get up on me or something like
that or you know or take advantage of me
i think it goes back to old scripts from
when i was a kid probably when i thought
that
somebody in a superior position i didn't
trust them and so it's just oh
it's just reading the old newspaper
sometimes you know so
uh
i think you're you're on you know you
i've i've even to this day
had you know like gone through exactly
what yeah you're saying yeah but what
i've learned now even within the last
like a little bit time is like
yeah you're gonna have to trust somebody
but
you don't have to trust anybody
to
with your money like if it's a manager
or whoever's going to help right then do
that but you don't need to be in control
of my money because then eventually that
that turned into power over your life oh
interesting so if you you want to be
able to trust your accountant right
right
and luckily i can trust mine right you
know what i mean cause everybody can't
trust theirs and that you know my
account saved my life wow yeah
he told you hey you got to put the
brakes on right here
he said he said
look at
hey riff i gotta need to talk to you
look at this this this this and i come
over there
okay
you know what i mean because everybody
ain't gonna ain't gonna show you because
some people are gonna be on the other
side
you see the thing with britney spears
like she couldn't even pick her lawyer
so if the lawyers are on the side with
whoever's controlling her then then she
has no hope
but if that lawyer said you know what
you can do this this this you don't got
to deal with this to now one person who
could
help that and fix all that but if you
got everybody playing against you now
you're screwed
and it's tough i bet at her level cause
you don't know who to trust then and if
you don't have power over your life
damn then then
you're basically just like a white a
white tiger in a cage
go make the money all right you're done
go back in here click yeah click click
all right cut off like she needs to rest
oh you need to rest yeah cool let's go
count this money
but and they put you a little money in
there with your food somebody right here
look look here's your hair and you're a
[ __ ] tiger you can't even spend no
money yeah you're gonna buy some damn
frosted flakes on out down bro
before you go if you did if if you did
get into politics though what do you
think about some of these gas prices man
honestly bro
could you do you think you could do
something um
well i heard you need a savior i heard
that the
and i forget where i heard this or maybe
i just saw it on instagram which again
goes back to the rumors you know oh yeah
who's that just who knows what but i
heard that the the gas isn't
disappearing people can oh they've been
making the same process of like making
the turn in whatever
i don't know how it works drilling for
oil or whatever
or turning something into you could make
your own gas we had a guy bus that made
his own gas but it burned off a lot of
his uh skin on his
it was his arms maybe her legs
he had big arms okay and small legs so
it's easy to
singe those puppies well easy to get it
confused when you're looking at him
he was doing handstands i mean he was
[ __ ] dude well bro he had this one
dude mr polito bro he [ __ ] made his
own gas bro and he actually died they
[ __ ] threw him in a ditch fire bro
why and he died i don't know why i
didn't know him that good
i think there's other things probably
that
that could
like
you can't run off water right well they
say you can't but we don't have a lot of
proof that you can't i mean i just feel
like if
if there was a way to you know you could
do solar power energy for houses yeah
put all the solar panels on why can't
you do that for the cars
i agree
or even if it's an old car put the solar
panels on and get a system cranked in
there and like
i feel like there's got to be a better
way than gasoline gasoline is dangerous
as [ __ ] yes i don't even like to cook
with gas
if it goes tick tick tick i'm opening up
all the windows
i'm opening up all the windows and i'm
ordering mcdonald's and i'm not even
eating it i'm just going to put it there
on the table yeah bro oh i turn in the
damn bruce willis every time they start
that [ __ ] i turn it i don't know yeah i
back away bro well the hell oh this has
gas so it's even better hold on wait
stop no it's not better i'm lying the
craziest thing is somebody will start
the tick tick tick then they'll start
telling you a story bro and they won't
even i'm looking at the windows like
damn bro open up every window and turn
on every fan
man people just don't want their life
some people don't want their life i
think some people don't just generally
don't don't care or maybe they aren't
even thinking about it because they're
so stressed out and anxiety of what they
got to deal with to fix
what's going on
that bad that just the software i got
that shaky software man is that is that
you know is that the system that we're
placing to be stressed out i think
everybody needs to spread the [ __ ] out
you think so i think that
really i don't know but i i'm not saying
i just i don't know i feel like if i get
by myself too much then i get real
lonely okay but then also if you get in
your new york you can't live in there
you got it it's like it's
it's like air body oh yeah bottom of the
barrel you start eating somebody will
finish applesauce for you right you know
yeah so
you know you halfway through something
slice them your
the damn aluminum moths
tag and go [ __ ] pawn it
before you can even finish your
tupperware sauce
dude you kind of like me and a lot with
nostalgia man you love nostalgia why do
you just installed my brain it's in my
you know that first 10 years of my life
it's it's it's there
it's just there
you love it man it's it's it's i i've
run off of it
yeah you know it's fascinating i do man
i love thinking about the past i love
thinking about moments from when i was
young and why did it impact me and what
what like yeah definitely and the
simplicity of things and how i was
thinking and feeling
a song a smell will bring you back there
or like a slow dance bro you ever
remember doing a slow dance at school or
nothing
i remember slow dancers
i don't think i ever did a slow dance
with boys to men or something
something like that what else would they
play yeah some people some boys man
you really loved basketball you loved it
that much huh
i love music too though yeah i remember
listening to my mom listening to
material girl in the car and i'm like
turn this one up and then after that you
change the station and it's jump chomp
chris girl somebody who's this yeah
what's these little kids that are
rappers and that [ __ ] was good it was
i had backwards everything on that point
bro i put backward paying back my shoe
people couldn't run couldn't walk
couldn't even get make it to school
anymore bro my [ __ ] was on people you'd
be wearing backwards your bows oh
skids were nice bruh especially when
they came out with the african cuts did
you have those skids
pants that must have been a uh texas
thing or florida thing
powwow peralta
skateboard we had jimmy
shirts that was jimmy z i think it was
or
varnette okay barnett we have no gecko
and we had silver
quicksilver barely made it by us bro
okay gotcha
nope we didn't have it
jabeau was huge bro people at jabot hill
figure did you ever was there a miller's
outpost
no that was in arizona i think wasn't it
miller's outpost that they went out we
didn't had that we had a lot of reebok
people wearing [ __ ] that said reebok we
had people with this paint reebok on
their [ __ ] okay
you know a lot of people still made
their own clothes bus and stuff like
that we'd have a dude and his sister you
could see their mom got a pattern of
fabric or something they'd both be
wearing like a purple silk or something
my mom made me a shirt one time hawaiian
shirt
she would make some like like that type
of
not that those colors but like one of
those type of styles damn that's cool
man
anybody ever make you any clothes
[Music]
oh yeah yeah
my my brother one time made me something
uh for christmas he tried to make me
something to try to make me uh uh
overalls bro okay okay how's that
that pan out
it was like a denim thong bruh that
[ __ ] just went right up around my ass
and on each shoulder bro
oh i was scared he wanted to [ __ ] bro
damn [ __ ] broke my heart dawg and then i
remember thinking he was trying to have
sex with me or you know being scared
about it and i would sleep at night i
put a little jingle bell on my body so
you could hear something moving in case
somebody came at me yeah i would hear it
okay damn bro it's just
i hated going to bed at night man i'd
have to set so many traps so nothing got
me
hmm
yeah i don't i don't think
yeah i sleep next to a gun
there you go bro i wish i would have i
wish i woulda now you're sleeping hotels
you're good yeah now get the best sleep
in hotels you think
just i don't know why if the sheets are
nice sometimes you get the sheets as
real you know the real gritty yeah
sometimes they're real gritty bro like
sleeping up i don't like to hear my leg
when i move it back and forth under the
sheet
yeah i put rain music
um 10 hours of rain
damn yeah wake up just soaking wet bruh
do you look dude do you listen to
anything or just silence i listen to
dead silence brothers waiting for god to
come get me damn
it's dark bro it's [ __ ] you can't
hear your dog
it's crazy when you and i are talking
and you don't [ __ ] dude wait so what
i'm grateful man you're the brightest
you aren't trying to go 100
i don't i mean i just
i can't i you know i i don't i i don't i
haven't slept that well probably in
about 17 years
but i'm planning on trying some new
stuff maybe yeah do you ever do do you
ever smoke no i only smoke at night oh
does it help it definitely helps
only at night though oh yeah i mean if i
don't got [ __ ] to do when somebody else
was driving
smoke during the day but
you know
but you ever took melatonin pills yeah
did that how'd that work they do pretty
good okay you maybe just i can't see
that far i notice it affects my sight oh
you do you do you wear glasses
i don't wear them that often sometimes i
wear them at the daytime okay
i got lasik surgery one time you did
best there was like a few life-changing
things i did
lasik surgery all right
well i watched what the what the health
and i
went to vegan like physical like changes
like i mean
not being having to put contacts in your
eyes you wake up you go in the bathroom
and like trying to put something in it's
like dry it's stuck to your finger yeah
one falls out your entire day is super
yeah somebody yeah play basketball one
falls out you got to get you got to stop
it you got to look for it
yeah yeah so lasik surgery change like
and vegan change your life yeah really
yeah it changed your life you speak
physical
physically changed my how i feel i was
getting up too late i kept getting up
late and i was breaking out my skin was
getting like and i was like something
gotta change you know what i mean
i had acne so bad i remember growing up
and somebody called me a [ __ ] she had
showed me though
she did
the the the uh it was like fourth of
july and i was sitting there i was
eating with my dogs i was on like
carnivore diet it was like
keto
keto keto keto yeah keto so we were
barbecuing i just moved forward i'm
barbecuing every day just oh dude steaks
hamburgers all this and it's like fourth
of july and then she showed me the um
documentary to what the health
and i changed you i was about to throw
it all away and then i just gave it to
the dogs
stop eating the meat man i stopped
breaking out crazy i stopped i got i
started sleeping better stop being like
being tired after i eat having a side
cramp after i had a big plate of ribs or
something like i thought that's just how
it felt you felt you know what i mean
i'm tired after i ate or glazed chicken
you know i mean honey glaze uh
teriyaki with a pineapple on top
yeah yeah yeah you're right though
yeah feeling tired i was like oh this is
i'm i eat you eat and then you go to
sleep that's like that's how it happens
like oh i'm tired
then once i went vegan and started doing
that for like a couple weeks i was like
oh eating them i was like more in it i
get actually more i get energy and i go
for a walk go play basketball go
anything
that's fascinating man yeah manchester
it's interesting how much you're in your
whole life you stay so caring about your
kind of your health and wellness it
seems like have you always been that way
no i
it wasn't until
like about three years ago
and and i watched that
there was a time period i mean like you
gave me those mangoes man yeah i think i
just been started being vegan pretty
much damn yeah i think i think but uh
and a woman's a a young lad it was a the
help of a woman brought that angel
earth angel
yeah
came in and changed my life i know
that's right have you ever been in love
before in your life
yeah
[Music]
i'm in love right now are you
yeah that's good for you man damn bro
yeah man i'm sorry oh you really bro
that's awesome dog thank you damn [ __ ]
bruh mm-hmm
trying to trying to get things
on on the right track yeah move forward
right way oh i was always afraid to say
when i was in love man
but but but here's the thing like you
see
like i think post malone just got
engaged you have a kid but you don't
gotta
like
the more you give the world
the more ammo especially with online
like like you know what i mean yeah
you don't want to
oh yeah you know keep some things to you
some some people cover the baby's face
they don't want to you know and then
mm-hmm so maybe maybe if they're in that
control environment maybe then you don't
have to you don't want to then you don't
have to you don't got to tell anybody
anything
yeah i could have five kids right now
nobody yeah you know what i mean yeah
you don't gotta tell us you don't own
nobody nothing
you know especially the world society
especially the society there's this day
and age
you're gonna tell them right now
yeah man it's a
it's an interest in society
well man i don't want to take up too
much more of your time bro we going a
bit you know dude i'm grateful man i i
just like hearing some of the stuff you
think about man it's interesting it's
different
yeah i i think a lot of a lot
do you think is it getting better though
yeah well i try to i try to when it when
it's if it's going something go like
like i was saying like looking at myself
from the outside if i'm just sitting
there and i'm
stewing in my own juices like yeah that
ain't that ain't good
and i think somewhere in the bible it
says something about like an idol mind
is yeah devil's playground or something
like that and i think
if you if you just try to even
but then
that could be why at night if i'm by
myself or whatever and i end up smoking
and listening to music
do some push-ups play with the play with
pups yeah do something
make some uh
tempered glass
that's a little dangerous from your
heart
yeah
infinity what pool or car
a car like an old-school one like that
oh yeah like a j30 or q45 and then get
the cream
pearl
paint
and then make the tint like this
i seen a uh dude this black dude had
real cream in it he had like it was like
like a aquarium kind of vibe
and that real cream and when he would
drive and like put on the brakes the
cream yeah
[ __ ] had a real two percent of
that [ __ ]
breast milk
oh his breath breath yeah if he had a
little tap off the back and he rolling
over there and getting a cup of dates
and then it gets swoops around dude what
if we are in the wrong we buying all
this other goose milk and all of this
and animal milk and we supposed to be
still having breast
there'll be milk
lot of saggy titties around here but
[ __ ] boy imagine people beating down a
mama's door just to get a sip at night
just
to be safe for the morning she'd
probably eventually have to call the
cops
on
but that'd be crazy my son's over here
trying to suck on my tits again
i'm sick of his little ass bruh
or i ain't he ain't even my real son she
might tell him damn he over here trying
to suck on my tits
well the police come and say
the police
what they say they come up
they'd be like
policia
you know what time it is come on open up
if he don't get it
we will
oh the next one we're helping they're in
on it yeah they won't everybody wants it
everybody wants that [ __ ] leg check
on mama's
damn boy that dose percent ooh
damn boy i [ __ ] dipped my dick in it
bro oh that [ __ ] of probably cause
imagine all the things mother's milk
could do man i can't believe we watch
what it does i don't know the science
science behind it i mean i know like
babies get and it's like that's all they
need right right apparently yeah imagine
if we kept having it
but that's the thing mothers get kind of
greedy they put that they stop it after
a couple of months or whatever everybody
shuts it down says uh uh it's out of
season
wait till august baby
let's see at starbucks
[Laughter]
it's a rap
that's a wrap man
rip thanks so much man uh hey so you
talked a little while ago about doing a
podcast man i if you you do one can i be
your first guest man
i think it's only right gotta have you
you gotta be we gotta do big i love to
we gotta do it oh i don't think i don't
know if you do things any other way man
but i would like to uh all right i don't
want to say i'm going to be a first
guest i would like to be a guest you no
you got to be the first guest and we're
going to
it's like the president thing
because if i if you don't if you don't
walk me all the way through it and
through the white house doors all right
i don't know where i'm going i'll end up
over there with uh [ __ ]
oh yeah you could do anything you can
end up whatever you know end up over
there with bob barker playing uh
plinko mm-hmm making my own plinko chips
out of them solder
solder grass and
caramel
two by fours with the cookie cutter sawn
it out dunking those down and uh
some type of formaldehyde
stain those
oh fresh put a um cherries jubilee on it
do you have a nice nice cherry glaze
nice cherry chupacabra
[Music]
i'll be outdoor bro when i die i want
them to throw me out of a plane bro and
see if i hit somebody on the ground damn
i dude you got to stop talking about
that
we're staying so 100. okay okay hundred
it is bro man dog hundred it is going
for a hundred all right man but as long
as we start your pie before then bro for
sure all right i'd love for 100. i'd
love to help man all right and get it
going um bro thank you so much man great
to see you and spend time with you dawg
you seem like you're doing good man i'm
all right
i'm right okay moving on up
hey man riffraff ladies and gentlemen
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like these leaves i
must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel it